quando noi youtuber da 5.000 iscritti
scopre il green screen signori
attualmente sono messo così solo che so
che stanno testando delle cose vediamo
come va
nel mentre signori miei siamo tornati su
gta e per me è come ritrovare l'amore
giochiamo al bodyguard scuse bodyguards
pound bodyguard michael a mi ha spronato
michael che mi protegge che carino ma
posso sfornare un animale voglio un
german shepard ma come mi fa da boa di
garza bello aspettative devo cambiare il
metodo fa schifo michael io ho bisogno
del mio cane protettore non ho bisogno
di te puoi anche morire maori morino
tranquillo è decisamente forte anno li
posso sparare a michael ma forse così
posso terminati secondo me adesso è
morto e cane non andare su for cani non
andare sul fuoco cane non andare
ti chiamerò fufi pieni fufi andiamo a
comandare in questo mondo incredibile
che ci ospita come michael e di come
comanda bene michael fu figlio e che
saremo i campioni del mondo come come
osi suonare a fufi come armati sparò le
gomme come osi suonare a fufi fufi devi
farti rispettare in questo mondo fu
fettine di far rispettare la gente non
ha ne frega niente di te come prima
tappa direi andare al ponte di santa
monica qualcuno mi dava una mano tipo
questo taxi qui cosa che ha detto ai
problemi non ho capito se i problemi ai
a funzioni picchia fucili picchia mordi
mordi fuggi bardi attacca tutti attacca
attacca attacca fu bacheca le sei
attacca ma non abbaiare così attacca
naja bravo fufi bravo fu hai provato a
metterti contro il fumo è morto non non
aveva l'anti l'anti rabbia ufficiale
rabbia tissimo figura che camera
e proprio un cane arrabbiato mai [ __ ]
gonfia cipressi la macchina per andare
al ponte di santa monica fratello ci
aspetta aspetta 22.100 da presta cinema
porca vacca togliti di qui sei pazzo
l'anno schivato tutti mamma mia fu firme
fatto veramente moriri fa mai più mai
via dalla strada sta insegnato a stare a
va bene ma io posso diventare un animale
ma veramente posso diventare un delfino
cosa è successo
e stato bellissimo nel sentire di cosa
caston schifo cos'è successo
vi sono suonati nude fine sono morto a
caso se tra una mucca non è vero non è
vero attualmente questo gioco ha
raggiunto una qualità estrema macro è
bellissimo mi scusi vorrei guidare se
possibile vorrei guida posso anche
imbracciare un fucile
non ho mai visto una mucca vabbè non
importa mi scusi vorrei guidare se
possibile una buca che che ruba una
macchina non arrestabile secondo me
giorno mi servirebbe cosa succedendo nel
mondo della cosa sto vedendo cosa sto
vedendo va bene io vivo la mia vita un
quarto di forfait cosa ci fai qua
ufficiali può fissare i sali in macchina
non mi conosci sono io sono io fufi
guardami pochi sono io la come fanno
riconoscermi mio canale ma non aias
amica perché sono una mucca che bello
vedere come una mucca crea panico per
strada non capitola fufi seguiti per
lavoro di dio vieni hai un tassista
no no no no non voglio che mi porti
voglio guidare io che poi non è che sia
fatto due domande che una mucca entrata
in taxi no no va bene dove ti porto alla
fattoria
vi siete mai chiesti come una mucca
presuntuosa ragazzi così fu figlia eva
tv che ti ammazzano a posso diventare
uno zoo una donna dello yoga wow
ciao faccio yoga aspetta che voglio
vedere se lo yoga aiuta a rilassarsi
almeno è quello che dico io la gente poi
non so sempre lusi bravo fujiyama fossi
una cosa fai sei pazzo fufi sono io fufi
non mi riconosci più
ecco mi sia effettivamente potevi non
riconoscermi perché ero un corpo adesso
mi riconosci fu chi sei pazzo non farei
mai più del male stupido cane lo stato a
caldo è così a posto a posto non volevo
fare il meno sono meritato me lo sono
meritato fufi fufi non mi costringe a
farti e fuffi a cuccia né partito non
volevo fu fino a volerlo dispiace ti
lancio l'osso stai tranquillo fino amico
6 fu fino a mi costringere fu fino a mi
costringeva fufi come io sono leggenda
nomi costringere non mi costringe a ian
non ti farò mai nel male lungi da me
voler far mara fufi però ha tutte le
ragioni persone incazzate posso
diventare un aquila che figo sono
un'altra coppa come come aspetta zitti
come faccio come si può si possa volare
non ci credo e bellissimo come funziona
con i suoi comandi non sono mai stato un
uccello vola vola possono epa vabbè ho
controllato il gioco della vita ma per
come ho fatto a non conoscerlo fino
adesso posso cagare sulla gente fatemi
che cosa sto vedendo una pila con un
fucile possono trovare le bombe no vabbè
fermi veramente non ci credo vada a eve
leva nova bel gioco del mondo passati
posso sganciare le bombe sulla gente
sganciato le bombe sono l'aquila
pentitevi pentite di esseri umani di
sgancio tutto io
altro che cagate in piazza duomo aquila
in autostrada sgancia bombe che al
panico è questa qua e la notizia che mi
manca posso usare naviga chiaramente sì
buongiorno pro non sparare
non è fatta solo per pellè che non vedo
come potresti sparare visto che stai
usando le ali per planare i nostri spara
con questo non ha sparato sganciare le
bombe basta porto quasi cazzata
quest'aquila piace proprio la faccia del
tipo hai usato darmi del cibo scadente
lurido umano hai usato darmi del cibo
scadente crepa e geniale sta roba che ci
dovremmo essere aspettavi passo vicino
al conducente per salutarlo buongiorno
non faccia caso all'aquila di fori sono
io a posto tutto bene si diverte qui io
mica gray addosso guidassero i poggio di
sopra lei faccia finta che non ci sia ma
perché se mi poggio di sopra poi magari
riesco a fare danno da qua sopra e
loggette non riuscirà giunta e la
polizia non riesce a raggiungermi che
sarebbe fighissimo eccolo
no l'ho fatta ma perché sotto nato umano
può fatto tornare umano dai ragazzi voi
parola vedere se riesco a far casino da
qua sopra e vedere se la polizia in
qualche modo mi raggiunge no e curiosità
più che altro ma do osb agliato target
vabbè chissenefrega alla famiglia e si
riesca a fare sta roba mi trasformo in
un qualsiasi cosa tipo maiale che
effetto e poi faccio sky followers
riesco a cadere dal cielo cosa cosa cost
cosa ve cosa ho visto anche questo è
l'aspetto di un porco che cade quando i
porci volano così si suol dire salve
tutto tutto tranquillo non si preoccupi
a posso tirare il parcheggio ok ok
ragazzino infatti caso a questa cosa che
state vedendo salve sono un maiale che
non è una giornata usuale per lei è una
cosa inusuale vedere un porco che vola
la de nunzio io ve lo dico
sono cascato pure nell'acqua limitese la
sta succedendo e il fantastico mondo di
harry potter questo queste ragazze era
l'arte della trasfigurazione se
trasformarsi in un animale molto
divertente bene adesso che abbiamo
sfatato questo mito abbiamo visto che i
porci volano speriamo riesca a fare
qualcos'altro tipo
trasformarmi in un top in coniglio bugs
bunny ma come che figata madama è
bellissimo ma dimmi che fa anche i salti
mi fa anno per la posso grattarmi
annusarli le zampe chiaro fucile a pompa
esatto era proprio quello che volevo mi
ha lasciato il gioco in compenso mamma
mia ragazzi con le macchine quelle
powers prove
mamma mia ragazzi la roba più [ __ ] di
sto gioco e che con la grafica al
massimo e le macchine quelle belle
powers secondo me mi scusi però quel
parcheggio è gratis offro io dicevo con
la grafica al massimo visto gioco qua se
aggiungi anche le macchine quelle belle
team patetico questa diventa una cosa
incredibile secondo me la mia scheda
grafica in questo momento sta implorando
gesù però vabbè di esplosivi lì o mio
dio aspetto voglia che tiri pugni ed
esplode la gente teoricamente aspetta ei
schifoso di un laido come osi come osi
puoi scendere con è molto peggio di
quello che pensavo ragazzi molto freddo
era abbastanza ovvio che io sarei
esploso in aria però non so se fate sta
roba magari mettetevi invincibile alla
teoricamente adesso dovrei essere
invincibile quindi se tifi con cazzotto
al camion questo gioco è la vita
cristiano nato dalla bandierina
attenzione proprio lui sotto l'incrocio
su ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
più la madonna cristiano ronaldo però in
questo video vi sia piaciuto
e lasciatemi delle idee qui sotto per i
prossimi giorni anche se ne farò un
miliardo e quindi iscrivetevi
preparatevi al peggio però essendo
ragazzi servizio bisogna c al momento mi
piace anche per i soci che come divi
adottata la descrizione se non sei da
con i siti iscrivetevi è come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo cazzotto
qualsiasi cosa mi ispiri in quel momento
bella ragazza
[Musica]